[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers hallo
und guten Abend ihnen allen die ganze
Welt war da aber ob sie wirklich
zusammenrückt und sich am Ende einigen
kann ist immer noch offen die
Weltklimakonferenz in Ägypten macht
bereits Überstunden es gibt dort viele
verpasste Chancen es gibt unwürdiges
Geschacher es gibt aber auch Meldungen
einer der größten Streitpunkte sei
gelöst nämlich die Frage wird es einen
Finanztopf geben für Klimaschäden in
ärmeren Staaten es wird ihm geben auch
wenn auch unklar ist wer zahlt aus Sharm
el-shake der aktuelle Stand jetzt von
Winnie Hischer und Elisa Miebach
es ist und bleibt zäh und es zieht sich
viele Delegierte sind schon abgereist
die Europäer noch nicht Europa hatte
hier ein Ziel wir sind als Europäer
angereist um ein neues Kapitel bei der
Klimagerechtigkeit aufzuschlagen in dem
wir die am meisten betroffenen Staaten
der Klimakrise am stärksten unterstützen
Gerechtigkeit heißt hier vor allem Geld
die ganze Konferenz ist von diesem Thema
dominiert dem hilfefond für Klimaschäden
die Chinesen haben bislang dazu
strategisch höflich geschieden am Abend
teilen Sie Ihre Vorstellung von
Gerechtigkeit mit
wenn ein vor etabliert wird sollte es
die Verantwortung und Pflicht der
Industrieländer sein zu spenden und die
Entwicklungsländer könnten das
freiwillig entscheiden
China entscheidet sich in diesem Fall
Entwicklungsland zu sein die Europäer
sehen das anders doch ihr Ziel China
zahlen zu lassen hat es nicht in den
letzten Entwurf geschafft die ärmsten
Länder wollen nicht Opfer sein dieses
geopolitischen Schachspiels
we don' wir brauchen nicht die Details
wer genau das Geld bekommt und wer genau
ist zahlt das können wir später
entscheiden aber wir brauchen eine
politische Entscheidung auf hoher Ebene
diesen vor in den nächsten Stunden zu
schaffen und ich hoffe das werden wir
alles hängt nun vom ägyptischen
Gastgeber ab der hat ein sehr eigenes
konferenzverständnis ließ am Morgen
schon alles abräumen fast so als wolle
er sagen es sei ihm egal wie diese
Konferenz endet der Verhandlungsleiter
sagt es so
jeder ja das volle Recht sich einem
Konsens anzuschließen oder nicht
anzuschließen
ohne Konsens aber scheitert diese
Konferenz noch hat die letzte Sitzung
nicht begonnen sie entscheidet über
alles
und wir bleiben dran für die meiste Zeit
des letzten Jahrhunderts war Katar ein
eintöniger wüstenfleck die Menschen
lebten mehr schlecht als recht vom
perlenfischen der internationale
Einfluss nicht messbar die Wüste gibt es
immer noch alles andere hat sich
grundlegend geändert morgen beginnt in
Katar das größte Fußballfest der Welt ob
es wirklich ein großes Fest wird ist
alles andere als sicher schon bevor es
losgeht hat allein die Tatsache dass ein
unfassbar Reiches Mini Emirat ohne große
Fußballtradition diese WM austrägt
vieles verändert den Ruf der FIFA den
Fußball selbst und auch Kater dass sich
der Welt als hochglanz-staat
präsentieren will und auf Kritik
allergisch reagiert goldene atai ist in
Doha
die erste Party ist gelungen die größte
fanszone in Doha wurde am Abend eröffnet
etwa 300.000 Katara freuen sich auf die
Gäste
Schellen ein Traum ist wahr geworden das
wird so Gott will die beste WM nicht nur
ein katarischer Traum sondern ein
arabischer Traum
von Partystimmung war bei ihm nichts zu
spüren wie verchef Gianni Infantino
nutzte den Morgen für eine Stunde der
Abrechnung mit den Medien und mit den
wm-kritikern in Europa statt auf deren
Kritik einzugehen setzte er auf
Gegenfragen und gegen Kritik
dieses moralische Lektionen erteilen das
ist einseitig
das ist nur heuchlerisch wir Europäer
sind es doch die uns für die nächsten
3000 Jahre entschuldigen sollten bevor
wir moralektionen erteilen
für Katha ist die WM ein
entwicklungsbeschleuniger neue Hotels
neue Straßen helfen und Flughäfen
ein neues Metronetz Katha wird
unübersehbar als Tourismus Geschäfts-
und Sportzentrum je mehr Ruhm je mehr
Netzwerke umso weniger Gefahr für das
kleine Land das sich eingezwängt sieht
zwischen mächtigen Nachbarn
die Sicherheit von katawa immer ein
großer bewegpunkt für die für die Eliten
in Katar und man versucht irgendwie
dieses Land zu etablieren auf der
Weltkarte und da ist natürlich so eine
Weltmeisterschaft gibt da natürlich eine
sehr tolle Möglichkeit das Land zu
etablieren die das Branding und die die
Marke Katar zu etablieren fast vier
Jahre blockierten die Nachbarn den Emir
cutters und beschuldigten ihn der
Sympathie für islamistische Terroristen
sie alle beendeten des embargo als die
WM Nate
mit der Medienmarke Al Jazeera schuf
sich Katar Einfluss und Gehör in der
Region
parallel machte es sich unverzichtbar
für den Westen als emsiger Vermittler
für Friedensgespräche ob mit den Taliban
mit palästinensin mit Iran
oder mit Afrika
[Musik]
Rom und Elend liegen dicht beieinander
in Katar eine WM auf Kosten der
Wanderarbeiter und in Sachen Frauen
Diskriminierung ein Land auf den letzten
Plätzen selbst im Vergleich mit den
arabischen Nachbarn
für weite Teile der Welt spielt all das
aber keine Rolle auch nicht für die FIFA
und ihren Chef Gianni Infantino
ja eine denkwürdige man kann auch sagen
merkwürdige Pressekonferenz des
fifa-chefs die mit einer fast anderthalb
stündigen Ansprache begann Theatralik
pur gucken wir noch mal rein
viele
katari
today I feel up
African
today I feel gay
eine Ansprache mit vielen Kunstpausen
Markus harm beobachtet für uns die FIFA
seit längerem guten Abend Markus in Doha
in Katar was war das heute für ein
Auftritt
ja ich würde sagen eine gescriptete Show
eine Propaganda Maschine von Johnny &
fantino ein einstündiger Monolog ins vor
der gesammelten Weltpresse und Janine
fantino hat genau das gemacht was die
Katara die Gastgeber sich wünschen denn
wenn man das vergleicht hast dann Alter
war die der Geschäftsführer des wm-okars
hat einen relativ ähnlichen
Gastkommentar in der englischen Zeitung
The Times geschrieben und man kann das
übereinander legen johnieren von Tino
hat sich sehr für Katar ausgesprochen
und sehr gegen den Westen und er hat es
versäumt Brücken zu bauen zu vermitteln
und ich finde er hat mehr Gräben
aufgerissen als zugeschüttet auch wenn
er in Teilen Recht hatte denn er hat
natürlich auch gesagt dass viele Firmen
Geld verdient haben in Katar und eben
nicht für die Migranten gerade gestanden
haben
kompensationsfonds gebildet haben also
er hatte in einigen Punkten Recht aber
er hat in weiten Teilen übertrieben
Kritik hat infant so als Heuchelei
zurückgewiesen heißt denn das an der
FIFA prallt einfach alles ab oder ist
diese Pressekonferenz heute gerade ein
Zeichen wie sehr die Umstände eben auch
der FIFA selbst zusetzen
ich würde sagen die Pressekonferenz hat
gezeigt wie sehr sich Johnny & fantino
gemein macht mit den katarern erlebt
hier seit acht Monaten er beantwortet
keine Fragen wer das bezahlt ob er sich
vielleicht einladen lässt vieles geht
durch die Hände der Katara und die FIFA
hat gar keine Entscheidungsgewalt mehr
man das zeigt er wie ähm wie schwach die
Organisation FIFA ist und sie müsste ja
eigentlich übergeordnet sein vermitteln
können und für den Fußball gerade stehen
und für die Welt und das verpasst die
FIFA durch eben die schwache Rolle von
Janine von Tino Markus herzlichen Dank
für diese Analyse live aus Kata und
ausführlich aus Katar berichtet
natürlich das aktuelle sportstudio
gleich nach uns
normalerweise ist das keine Frage für
Fußballfans nicht und für die die alle
vier Jahre rechtzeitig zum Weltturnier
fußballfans werden auch nicht Vorfreude
garantiert
diesmal ist vieles anders und das liegt
nicht nur am Wetter Roman Lesko war aus
Berlin
Protest gegen die WM heute direkt vor
dem Reichstag extinction Rebellion
kritisiert die kathavergabe nur ein
Steinwurf entfernt gähnende Lehre wo
sonst hunderttausende feierten bei
Temperaturen um den Gefrierpunkt keine
Fanmeile von Feierstimmung auch in der
Farbe fußballkneipe keine Spur Besitzer
und Stammgäste machen mit bei der
Boykott Kata Initiative statt
gemeinsames gucken gibt es ein
Alternativprogramm Vorträge etwa zum
Thema Menschenrechte wir werden am
Wochenende Fußballspiele besuchen gehen
und Amateurbereich und auch
frauenfußballspiele
und dann werden wir ganz normal das
kneipenprogramm haben im Amateurbereich
ein Zeichen setzen will auch der queere
Sportverein Vorspiel auf einer großen
Berliner Sportanlage planen Sie ein
protestfußballturnier kicken statt
gucken das Motto am 10 Dezember dem Tag
der internationalen Menschenrechte
wir haben Quere Teams aus ganz
Deutschland aus Hamburg aus München
natürlich auch einige aus Berlin wir
haben Teams aus England dabei die extra
herkommen gänzlich verschwunden ist die
Sportbegeisterung aber nicht
ausgelassene Stimmung etwa in der
Berliner magnetbar es sind dänische
Touristen kurz vor dem Start in Katar
jubeln sie ihren Frauen bei der Handball
WM zu hier wird ab morgen Fußball
gezeigt der Besitzer hat häufig
internationale Gäste aus Brasilien oder
Japan etwa erzählt hätten sie das dort
weit weniger kontrovers diskutiert werde
seine Hoffnung dass diese Fans hier ins
Gespräch kommen dass ihn auch ein
Eindruck bekommen was passiert hier
eigentlich wie ist die Berichterstattung
in Deutschland warum ist das hier so ein
großes Thema die können hier zusammen
auch diskutieren in anderen Kneipen
rollt der Ball bereits zumindest auf dem
Tisch und natürlich wird schon jetzt
diskutiert noch nie dürften die
Meinungen zum Thema Fußball schauen so
weit auseinander gelegen haben sportlich
Sport und ich guck mal das sehr wohl an
glaube ich der Boykott bringt uns jetzt
auch nicht weiter
die Phase werde ich gar nicht gucken und
dann hinten raus muss man halt gucken
längst nicht alle Fußballkneipen werden
die WM boykottieren viele aber wohl auf
lebhafte Diskussionen hoffen
so und den Überblick über alles was
heute auch noch wichtig ist hast jetzt
du Hanna genau kommenden Mittwoch Tag ja
der Vermittlungsausschuss um einen
Kompromiss im Streit über das geplante
Bürgergeld zu finden heute machte
CDU-Chef März dazu deutlich die
Ampelkoalition müsse einen großen
Schritt auf die Union zu gehen es
müssten Anreize gesetzt werden schnell
wieder Arbeit zu finden sagte märz auf
dem Deutschlandtag der Jungen Union in
Fulda zuvor war Johannes Winkel dort zum
neuen Vorsitzenden der Jungen Union
gewählt worden in Nordrhein-Westfalen
erfolgt auf Tilman Kuban
bei seinem ersten Besuch in Kiew Fahrt
Großbritanniens neuer Premierminister
sunack dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski weitere Unterstützung zugesagt
konkret ging es in den Gesprächen um
Flugabwehrgeschütze und Technologie zur
drohnenabwehr die neuen Hilfen haben
einen Umfang von rund 57 Millionen Euro
mit Blick auf den Winter soll außerdem
die humanitäre Hilfe ausgeweitet werden
um den Ukraine Krieg ging es auch beim
Treffen der asiatisch-pazifischen
Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft in Bangkok in
ihrer gemeinsamen Abschlusserklärung
verurteilte die große Mehrheit der
Mitgliedstaaten den angriffskriegs habe
allerdings auch andere Ansichten gegeben
zu den apec-mitgliedern zählen neben den
USA auch Russland und China
um sich solidarisch mit den
regimekritischen Protesten in Iran zu
zeigen sind in mehreren Städten
Deutschlands erneut tausende Menschen
auf die Straße gegangen wie hier in
Hamburg die Demonstrierenden forderten
unter anderem den Sturz der iranischen
Führung in Berlin versammelten sich laut
Polizei rund 2000 Personen und
erinnerten auch an die Opfer des Regimes
und jetzt die Lottozahlen die lauten 4
13 20 21 34 42 Superzahl 0 alle Angaben
wie immer ohne Gewähr
wird noch der Blick aufs Wetter morgen
zwischen Nordrhein-Westfalen und Sachsen
länger sonnig sonst viele Wolken und
zeitweise Regen oder Schnee 0 Grad im
Nordosten bis 10 Grad im Südwesten auch
in der neuen Woche wechselhaft mit Regen
anfangs auch noch Schnee oder Schnee
Regen dazwischen aber auch etwas Sonne
ein bis 11 Grad
der Winter ist da und ab morgen auch die
WM wir kommen wieder um 21:45 Uhr und
freuen uns auf sie aber erst wünschen
wir Ihnen einen angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Musik]